hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Chapter 14 of
after virtue Alistair MacIntyre is going
to talk about institutions and the roles
that they play in relation to practices
and virtues and so we should remind
ourselves you have to start what he
means by institutions it's a little bit
broader than what we might typically
associate with that term it could be
something that's that's a physical
community that has its own space think
about a hospital as an institution for a
whole set of practices or a medical
group maybe that way a company could be
an institution there may be actual
institutions like that you know
foundations for things schools or
institutions all sorts of other things
that we would normally call institutions
but he gives us some some other examples
as well when he wants to clarify the
difference between practices and
institutions
so he says chess physics and medicine
are practices chess club's laboratories
universities and hospitals are
institutions so a club could indeed be
an institution or we might even think
about certain discourses
as being institutions and one that came
to my mind as I was preparing to talk
about this especially when we're
thinking about virtue ethics is there's
there's a lot of people out there who
have you know coaching packages that you
can buy and ebooks and all sorts of
things about the virtues that are
basically garbage because they they
don't really understand virtue in any
sense other than just being character
traits that we think of as good they
understand in a very human sort of not
even quite human way more like a human
light way and they pedal and pander this
sort of thing and those would be
examples of institutions that are not
doing a good job in fostering the
virtues we could think of other things
as well in which people are deliberately
focusing on virtue ethics or there's a
bit more of a robust engagement a prime
example would be the International
Society for MacIntyre Ian's inquiry
which is a bunch of people who are you
know very focused on Alistair McIntyre
and and his works and theory and apply
it in a lot of other ways which
comprises people from Marxists all the
way over to to Thomas and everything in
between
that would be an institution and
MacIntyre himself by talking about
things in this way would be saying well
that institution it's important but it's
never going to be exactly the same thing
as the virtues or the practices that are
being sustained by them so in order to
understand this let's look first at
again what MacIntyre tells us about
virtue itself he tells us this is a
partial definition of a virtue a virtue
is an acquired human quality the
possession and exercise of which tends
to enable us to achieve those goods
which are internal to practices and the
lack of which effectively prevents us
from achieving any such goods he tells
us this is preliminary he's going to
give it a further amplification later on
but this is this is good so it's it's an
acquired human quality it's something
that we develop and we
we have to possess it and exercise it
when we do that we're able to achieve
Goods internal to practices so we're
able to do the things that the practices
you know have as the Telos and if we
don't have these things then we won't be
able to actually do the things that the
practices are about we won't practice
the practice as well and so virtue is
always required and McIntyre in this
chapter actually picks out three that he
thinks are particularly architectonic or
you know ruling or necessary those are
justice honesty and courage now how does
this tie in with with what he has to say
about practices he reminds us that
although practices do involve technical
performance and skills and standards
they are never just a set of technical
skills so let's take a look at what what
he says about this this is quite
important he says a practice in the
sense I intend is never a set of TechNet
estatic technical skills even when
directed towards some unified purpose
and even if the exercise of those skills
can on occasion be valued or enjoyed for
their own sake what makes it more than
that says what's distinctive in a
practice is in part the way in which
concept conceptions of the relevant
goods and ends which the technical
skills serve and every practice does
require this exercise are transformed
and enriched by these extensions of
human powers and by that regard for its
own internal goods partially to death
definitive of each particular practice
or type of practice so there's a
long-winded way of saying there's always
more going on with the practice
technical skills are part of it but
there's a Telos there's a purpose to it
so medicine is not just about doing
things you know in a certain way to
human bodies
you know surgeon may be very very good
but the surgeon actually needs to know
which organs to keep in and take out you
know for the the purpose of better
health of the person just because they
can cut them
open and rearrange things doesn't mean
they should as a matter of fact probably
they should be rather circumspect in
that you know an anesthesiologist may
get a real kick out of putting people
under but that doesn't mean they need to
put people under all the time there's a
given purpose to it and it fits within a
matrix of other practices and so virtue
would come in and be quite important
with that we could talk about other
medical things as well so these always
involve these practices always involve
Goods and ends that are transformed or
enriched McIntyre also points out that
practices as practices have histories
they even have traditions some of them
may change the goods that they're about
in the course of that he says practices
never have a goal or goals fixed for all
time for example painting has no such
goal nor he has physics but the goals
themselves are transmuted by the history
of the activity the historical dimension
is crucial in relation to the virtues
you can think of the virtues as things
that run like threads throughout this
history but the virtues themselves are
also being learned in the course of a
history as well we have a more developed
conception of what honesty would entail
if we've actually subordinated ourselves
and to the to the materials and studied
these things in the present then people
did say in Homeric Greece so this brings
us to the really key point what's the
relationship between practices and
virtues which people have people engage
in and can be understood in this kind of
general or abstract way and then the
nitty-gritty of the actual world that we
live in in which practices generally
take place within
and fostered by what we can call
institutions so in for example you can
practice medicine anywhere you want to
you know doctors used to make a lot more
house calls and go around with their
kits and bring it where it where they
would go
although the kid itself is part of an
institution you might say right a larger
one
letting the doctor in recognized them as
being a medical professional that's all
you know a social institution as well
and there are good doctors and there are
bad doctors there are doctors who abused
the privilege of being able to operate
on prescribe diagnose and there are
doctors who used it for you know to
promote great good among people and we
can talk about other things similarly so
there are institutions that support that
house that teach that make it possible
to continue practices what is the
relationship between them
a lot of times people will make the
mistake of identifying a practice with
an institution and as a side note if we
think about certain kinds of practices
and certain kinds of institutions
oftentimes institutions try to attain a
monopoly over that practice don't they
which can be good in some respects but
often times can be quite problematic it
can set things back it can prevent
innovation or it can promote innovation
but of the wrong sort innovation by
itself is not necessarily a good thing
so practices as he says are not the same
things as institutions they must not be
confused with institutions why he says
institutions are characteristically and
necessarily concerned with what I've
called external goods they are involved
in making money
and other material goods they are
structured in terms of power and Status
and they distribute money power and
status as rewards and McIntyre is not
knocking them for doing that
he says they couldn't do otherwise if
they're to sustain not only themselves
but also the practices of which they are
the bearers and there's this perpetual
tension which by the way we like to have
an
in television shows I know I'm using a
lot of medical examples here so maybe
we'll think about some other ones in a
bit but what comes to mind is that in
all the medical shows or you've got this
great doctor who thinks outside the box
and there's a diagnostician and you know
also goes through tough moral you know
experiments and situations and decides
on the right thing or if they do the
wrong thing they feel bad about it
afterwards right you recognise this
character don't you and then you have
the hospital administrator who's always
the stick in the mud saying no you can't
do that
the rules say this we have to think
about the hospital board we have to
think avoid lawsuits we have to well
both of them are necessary right because
the the hotshot star doctor can only
operate within an institution that
continues functioning and likewise the
hospital administrator who's all you
know just a bean-counter
all about the the dollars and cents well
they're not actually practicing medicine
they are they're practicing something
within that framework it might be
accountancy it might be keeping an
institution running those are practices
as well all right but it's not medicine
as such you need both of those in order
to sustain an institution and you can
say the same thing about football teams
you can say the same thing about any
other kind of company musicians are a
great example you can have virtuoso
musicians who there are so many bands
who were disappointed that we only have
a few albums of why because their
management was garbage either they're
managers you know stole all their money
or they couldn't get them onto the
record labels or they just you know
couldn't get them into shows and
eventually they had to call it quits
having good managers is really an
important thing and this is where some
people could shine you know in
institutions I'll give you a prime
example from the world of heavy metal
one band that has stuck out for a very
long time and has had some you know
fights within the band and some
dysfunction but it has been a
prime example of a well-functioning
institution most of the time would be
Iron Maiden and why is that the case it
would be because there is one person
there were many other people involved in
this as well but there was one person
who thought of it in institutional terms
really from the start and that would be
the bassist Steve Harris who technically
is one of the best bassist in the heavy
metal world recognized by a jazz bassist
of people from other genres as being an
incredible musician but it was also
really really good at running a band and
so that's part of what's needed in
institutions does that mean that the
practice is within that are always going
to be recognized he says no practices
can survive any length of time
unsustained by institutions let's use
the music example you've got these great
players Bruce Dickinson one of the
greatest singers Steve Harris one of the
greatest bassist you know these two
amazing guitarist Adrian Smith and Dave
Murray two different really great
drummers the late Clive Burr and Nicko
McBrain and you know we've had a singer
come in from time to time
there's also Yannick gars people are
kind of you know off and on about him as
the the third guitarist and you you put
these people apart separately they can
all there are all wonderful musicians
they can all do incredible stuff but
they don't exist as that band without
that institution keeping it together
that's why when Paul Di'Anno
plays Iron Maiden standards it's not
really Iron Maiden it's Paul Di'Anno
their original singer viewing that so in
order to sustain certain kinds of
practices and the goods that are to be
achieved within that you need the
institutions but he says that
institutions are also often corrupting
he says that without justice courage and
truthfulness practices cannot resist the
corrupting power of institutions you
know
and what are the sort of corruption we
might think of well making the wrong
decisions based on external goods rather
than goods internal to the practice
institutions value those external Goods
more in some cases than they do the
internal goods so he tells us that if
institutions do have corrupting power
than making and sustaining of forms of
human community and therefore of
institutions itself has the
characteristics of a practice and
moreover of a practice which stands in a
peculiarly close relationship to the
exercise of the virtues in two important
ways the exercise of the virtues is apt
to require a highly determinate attitude
to social and political issues and it's
always within some particular community
with its own specific institutional
forms that we learn to fail we learn or
fail to learn as exercise the virtues as
a matter of fact McIntyre at one point
not in this work but in in personal
conversations called the family the
original school of desire the place
where we we learn what to value what not
to value what to prioritize we become
virtuous or vicious based on that so the
the the virtues are needed the virtues
are required in order to keep
institutions from corrupting practices
in order to keep institutions honest you
might say right and at the same time
virtues themselves need institutions
they're developed within frameworks
they're developed within particular
societies and within particular
institutions in societies he tells us
the virtues are themselves in turn
fostered by certain types of social
institution and endangered by others so
this is a very important set of
interconnected relations you can't do
without institutions you have to have
them and yet by themselves institutions
aren't enough and there's this constant
Asian to think that the institution is
what matters when it's really the
practices and the virtues that matter
more that the institution is supposed to
be supporting and in turn the virtues
help to make sure that the institution
doesn't go off the rails and subordinate
its practices that it's supposed to be
fostering just to the desires needs of
those running the institution or those
who the institution caters to so there's
a very complex dynamic here that
MacIntyre wants us to be attentive to
you